une décision qui vient troubler l'unité
du droit européen
elle vise directement les moyens
d'action de la bce et en particulier la
légitimité de sa politique d' aide à la
zone euro par le rachat de dette
publique une décision qui passe mal
auprès de l'exécutif européen
la présidente de la commission ursula
von der leyen a ainsi pris la défense de
la bce et fait planer la menace d'une
sanction contre berlin la commission
européenne a la tâche de sauvegarder le
fonctionnement correct du système de
l'euro et du système juridique européen
nous examinerons de possibles prochaine
étape qui pourra inclure l'option d'une
procédure d'infraction
les juges de karlsruhe ne se sont pas
arrêtés au programme européen de rachats
de dette publique
ils ont également remis en question la
compétence de la cour européenne de
justice
institution qui contrôle la légalité des
actes des différentes institutions de
lieux et donc de la bce
un point sur lequel ursula von der leyen
a également tenu à répondre
elle a rappelé la compétence absolue des
juges européens
la politique monétaire de l'union est
une compétence exclusive le droit
européen prévoit sur le droit national
les jugements rendus par la cour de
justice européenne sont contraignants
pour les cours de justice nationale la
parole ultime sur le droit européen est
rendu au luxembourg en attendant la cour
constitutionnelle allemande a fixé un
ultimatum à la banque centrale
européenne d'ici trois mois la bce doit
justifier la conformité des rachats de
dette publique avec les traités
européens
si elle ne le peut pas la bundesbank la
banque centrale allemande devra cesser
de participer aux programmes de relance
européens